ん
par ん
goo
t ジョイ
[音楽]
a
を塗った
の
はいえ
[音楽]
ちょっ
どういう状況か分からないんですけど
見られています
こんにちははじめ社長ですというわけで俺の初6ネイルなんですけども買った時は黒
そして色々あってピンク色になってしまいましたが今回さらにこの初力の色 d dur
しようと思いますあのとりあえずピンク色の車にして良かった点は8かっこいい
あと滅茶苦茶目指す
そんぐらいですねピン黒に青悪かった点はへとめっちゃ
考察されますねを盗撮してもいいと言わんばかりのからなんで僕はおとなしくピースし
てました
ホントにマジで目立つですよも静岡でこの車見たら僕確定なんでチャット不便でしたと
いうわけで色を変えていきたいと思いますそして急なことにこのタイミングでもうすぐ
リュッ
10番端が遊びにくるんやなお前いった贈るというのを考慮して果たして僕はこの86
の車の色何色にするんでしょ
このいくで1個4
はぁ
がとうございます
それ a
再会ありがとうございます
外も気に入ってたんですけどもう一チェンジしたくてっているなんですけどイメージの
人がいまして
保変の色っぽく車をしていただきたいなと言うかどうなんですかができます
ねございますはいございます
山さんのちょうどあいつはけどちょっと短い期間だったんですけども
このピンとくる人
お別れねー
[音楽]
入っちゃ宜しくお願いします
ああああああ
[音楽]
こうして私肇社長はピンクの髪力との最後の別れを迎えたのであったっ
ハイ2期であれから2週間ほどたちました
再び55地蔵さんに来ております
塗装ありがとうございました敵の方はつの敵はもう簡単
ほんとず買うんです2
小沢鑑定までズームしていただいて早速
彼らの86
お願いします
ん
うん
[音楽]
ran
東映学校行くないですか
めっちゃ扱いづらいカーペッツいがっこいいふうにかっこいいぞ
あれすげー
ありゃー
ん
[音楽]
いいし
玉淀内でもまあそういうわけで偶然いいえ
色変更完了しましたお正じゃあなぁ本番
まあ
ああああああ
ん
おっ
というわけでピンク色だった髪6判全203のたびになってしまいまし
ねえええこれやばくない奥さん来るまで肌でこのセンターに入ってるのを見ました
めっちゃ綺麗に出来てるんですちょっといろいろ見ていきましょう細かいところ
[音楽]
はいそんなわけで食べ3カラーのお車にしていたんですけども
思ったより格好良かっためちゃくちゃかっこいい感じになって
なんかちょっと悔しいですねこっちが込んだすごい悩んでて
黄色にするか金にするかっていう並んでたんですけども金なかなか薄い感じになったん
でもういっそのことキーラっぽい感じにオチってもらいました
ひかりさんの金髪をちょっと黄色っぽい感じだったと思うのでこれでほぼ管理ヒカル母
になってると思いますそれだけであとは聞かずさんの到着を待ちましょうほな
[音楽]
me
バッハ